[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
samira ist acht jahre alt geworden und
wir feiern übermorgen ihren
kindergeburtstag und sie hat sich eine
meerjungfrau traut von mir gewünscht
heute überraschend sehen mit der torte
ich habe sie heute schon fertiggestellt
heute ist bei uns freitag übermorgen am
sonntag ist die geburtstagsparty und ich
zeige euch wie ihr diese meinung frau
torte backen könnt wie ihr sie vor
backen können und vorbereiten könnt so
dass wir dann auch eben zwei tage später
wirklich richtig toll schmeckt ich hab
es leider als ich mich hat so ein
bisschen erwischt ich bin eigentlich
krank und sollte im bett legen aber für
die sanierung mache ich das natürlich
deswegen ist meine stimme leider ein
bisschen angeschlagen
samira du darfst jetzt kommen warte ich
für dich rein der torte nämlich noch
nicht gesehen
[Musik]
ich mache die lasten noch kurz zu und
auf 31 23 und guck mal hinter dir toll
habe ich drei tage finde ich gebacken
oder zwei vorbereitet und gut trocknen
lassen genau denken wahrscheinlich viele
oh mein gott ich möchte meine tochter
oder meinen sohn auch gerne mit ort
überraschen aber das kriege ich niemals
in arbeit ist es gar nicht so ist
wirklich einfach nur ein richtig gutes
timing haben das heißt die deko elemente
sowie die acht die schwanzflosse und die
figur die habe ich bereits drei vier
tage vorher gemacht den kuchen dann
einen tag vorher gemacht und so wird
dann wirklich alles rechtzeitig fertig
und ich zeige euch jetzt wird diese
torte auch selbst backen können
das sind kekse jetzt bereite ich zuerst
den teig so dafür gebe ich die eier
gemeinsam mit dem zucker salz und
vanille extrakt in eine rührschüssel und
lasst sie dann für etwa 5 minuten
schaumig aufschlagen schreibe ich hier
noch die zitronenschale dazu und gibt
anschließend dann das öl und die
buttermilch dazu die zwei zutaten höre
ich jetzt nur bei geringer stufe 1
zum schluss kommen dann noch die
trockenen zutaten mit rein und natürlich
auch noch die zucker streusel diese habe
ich dann mit einem schneebesen ganz
vorsichtig unter den teig fühle ich
jetzt in zwei back ringe mit 24 und 18
cm durchmesser
[Musik]
jetzt gibt's alles füllen der torte und
ich habe mir jetzt gedacht ich mache
eine schiffsparade buttercreme da findet
ihr das rezept bereits auf einem kanal
buttercreme die musste wirklich nicht
schwer schmecken und ich werde die
buttercreme verfeinert mit waldfrüchten
und dann schmeckt sie wirklich richtig
lecker ihr könnt bei der zubereitung
einfach mal noch mal in dem anderen
video nachschauen
da zeige ich euch die zubereitung auf
dem wasserbad wer aber der
küchenmaschine mit hitze funktion hat
kann es auch ganz einfach hier machen
geht nämlich einfach es gibt hier
nämlich einfach die zutaten also eiweiß
zucker und salz an die rührschüssel und
dann ist nur ganz wichtig dass die masse
für etwa zehn minuten lang auf 70 grad
erhitzt wird sodass wirklich auch kaymer
und salmonellen abgetötet werden kann
danach wird die creme kalt geschlagen
zudem errang die besemer für mit kalt
geschlagen und dann mit der weichen
butter um mit dem bruder zu erfahren
und habe ich jetzt die waldfrüchte
einfach püriert und in einem topf
einkochen lassen
wirklich so dass fast die komplette
flüssigkeit weg ist und hier möchte ich
jetzt die kerne nicht dabei haben
deswegen werde ich sie durch ein
haarsieb streichen
[Musik]
jetzt nach zehn minuten kann ich die
temperatur unternehmen das heißt nach
zehn minuten nehmt ihr auch die eismasse
vom rabatt herunter und jetzt ist ein
ganz wichtiger schritt diese weiß maße
muss jetzt wirklich wieder kalt gerührt
werden hier im hintergrund für ich
gerade schon die butter mit dem was man
im extrakt und puderzucker
die muss auch ganz weiß schaumig gerührt
werden diese passte dieser frucht masse
mich ist auch abkühlen und dann kann ich
erst alles miteinander verbinden und ich
uns jetzt einfach so zwischenzeit schon
mal um die trockenen böden bericht zu
schreiben
[Musik]
die pc masse ist schön abgekühlt die
butter ist jetzt auch schön weich und
die frucht masse ist auch abgekühlt das
heißt jetzt kann ich einfach alles
zusammen gehören
mit einem schneebesen und kann gleich
die torte für
[Musik]
jetzt wird die torte gefüllt ich habe
zwar in der trotte dreh platte dann eine
silikon matte und ein cache bord ich
nehme zwar wiederverwendbare kate box
kommt ein bisschen von der buttercreme
auf skateboard damit die torte nicht
runter rutscht damit der erste boden und
dann nämlich meist einen aus der mitte
und die unterseite die nämlich später
als deckel damit die torte schön gerade
wird jetzt immer hier ein bisschen
buttercreme drauf streichen
die kids freuen sich aber im abschnitt
wenn man dann diese schönen
zuckerstreuer sieht dann kommt jetzt die
frucht einlage wo die habe ich hier
einfach in tellern gemacht und habe
jetzt etwa frucht einlagen gemacht und
bei frucht anlagen ist immer nur wichtig
dass sie vom rand her bis hinweg bleiben
das heißt ich mache sie meistens sechs
zentimeter kleineren durchmesser als die
torte und dann ist es immer schön in die
torte drin
dies ist noch nicht ganz gefroren aber
das ist nicht schlimm jetzt wieder creme
drauf und dann die torte so vollständig
füllen
[Musik]
die dort habe ich nach dem füllen eine
stunde gekühlt und jetzt nehme ich
einfach die restliche buttercreme und
stress sie glatt zuerst eine erste
schicht damit die die krümel behindert
und dann eine zweite schicht und damit
die torte richtig schön glatt
[Musik]
ich beginne jetzt mit dem modellieren
der meinung frau dafür nehme ich ein
stück weiße blüten passte und um die
hautfarbe hinzubekommen gebe ich dann
noch etwas gelbe rote und rosa
lebensmittel verpasste dazu aus der
blüten passte form ich jetzt eine kugel
für den kopf und dann noch eine kleine
stupsnase aus der gleichen masse form
ich dann noch zwei arme aus weißem und
schwarzem von dann stecke ich jetzt
kleine kreise aus und klebt sie dann
noch mit essbarem kleber auch um das
gesicht zu modellieren
so entstehen dann die augen der jungfrau
mit etwas weißer zucker schrift x ich
dann noch die lichtpunkte ins auge mit
schwarzer lebensmittelfarbe malich die
wimpern der meerjungfrau damit der kopf
später an der torte hand befestigte ich
jetzt noch zwei zahnstocher mit etwas
essbarem kleber auf der unterseite des
kopfes aus braunem von dann vorm ich
jetzt noch die haare der meine frau und
die klebe ich dann wieder mit s-bahn
kleber an den kopf
[Musik]
hier habe ich jetzt bereits ein stück
gelangen von dort mit cnc pulver
verknetet daraus entsteht jetzt die
schwanzflosse der jungfrau das ende
drücke ich jetzt flach schneide es in
form und struktur ihre es anschließend
um die flosse später in die torte
stecken zu können befestige ich auch
hier zwei spieße mit essbaren kleber mit
einer lok hülle könnt ihr hier ganz
einfach die schuppen struktur herstellen
ich habe ich ein stück weißen von don't
diesen habe ich ebenfalls mit cmc pulver
verknetet damit später gut aushärtet und
daraus freue mich jetzt eine 8 auch hier
befestige ich jetzt im zahnstocher damit
ich später die acht nach dem aushärten
schön in die torte stecken kann
anschließend freue mich dann noch kleine
muscheln schnecken seesterne und andere
dinge die man am meeresboden findet
[Musik]
jetzt freilich noch ein stück weißen
fondant ganz dünn aus und diesen steche
ich dann mit buchstaben ausstellern aus
[Musik]
die deko teile sind jetzt getrocknet und
jetzt werde ich etwas metallic farben
nehmen und sie damit bestreuen
ihr könnt aber auch zum beispiel im pool
farbe nehmen und einfach mit dem pinsel
so ein bisschen drüber pulver
[Musik]
wenn die eine seite getrocknet ist drehe
ich die deko teile noch um um gespräche
dann auch noch von der rückseite
alternativ könnt ihr die farbe natürlich
auch mit einem pinsel auftragen
[Musik]
das magazin noch samir us namensschild
dafür möchte jetzt eine muschel machen
für skateboard ich habe bereits ein
kickboard ausgesucht und zwar ist meine
torte am in der so groß ich werde sie
dann nicht ganz in die mitte setzen und
sondern eher an den rand und hier unten
ist dann noch platz für eine muschel
ich habe ich jetzt wieder modelliermasse
also von land und leuten pasta gemischt
und rollte jetzt aus nicht ganz dünn
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich ihnen runden ausstecher
seit ich daraus dem hochschul so
schneide ich hier am rand ein bisschen
was weg
[Musik]
und jetzt brauche ich hier noch den
unteren part
[Musik]
und damit ihr muss jetzt noch
strukturiert und dafür könnte zum
beispiel ein zahnstocher nehmen oder
einen holzspieß und hier nehme ich jetzt
einfach modeln werkzeug zum
strukturieren
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich einfach ein bisschen
metallic screen rosa sprüht in den
deckel und kann dann mit dem pinsel die
ränder beim malen einfach so von außen
machen
[Musik]
mit etwas essbarem kleber klebe ich dann
noch die buchstaben von samira auf die
muschel
[Musik]
jetzt kommt endlich die von der decke
auf die torte
ich habe jetzt hier 214 lila und zwei
päckchen weißen von dann das lila ist
ein richtig schönes die la ich möchte
aber ein bisschen passt der liga machen
und mich deswegen mit dem weiß gut durch
[Musik]
denn von dann rolle ich jetzt auf etwas
becker sterkel circa 3 bis 5 mm dünn aus
und damit decke ich jetzt die untere
torte komplett ein
den überrest schneidet dann mit einem
marzipan messer bündig an der torte weg
mit zwei von dann klettern glättet dann
noch die torte damit ich ganz saubere
kanten bekomme drehe ich die torte mit
dem torten ritter um und das ist dann
die upside down methode die obere torte
denke ich mit einer schicht weisen von
band 1 und auch diese drehe ich dann
wieder oben damit ich die ränder richtig
schön sauber und eckig bekommen
[Musik]
jetzt geht es an die deko der unteren
pforte dafür werde ich jetzt ein paar
meerjungfrau schuppen dran machen
ich habe jetzt hier vier farben
ausgesucht rosa hellblau lila und weiß
habe den verband bin ausgerollt und dann
mit einem struktur roller wieder darüber
gerollt
und jetzt kann ich die schuppen
ausstechen ich habe jetzt hier zwei
ostereier ausstecher also zwei ovale
ausstecher ich werde jetzt den kleineren
benutzen und kann jetzt aber vorher also
wer möchte kann da auch noch ein
bisschen glitzer mit reinbringen
das nehme ich wieder das metallic screen
den deckel und geht es gerade so ein
bisschen drüber
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich mit einem ausstecher
einfach die schuppen ausstechen und
diese dann halbieren
[Musik]
lebst die einzelnen schuppen überlappend
an die torte ich habe jetzt hier oben
eine markierung festgesetzt s-bahn
kleber drauf gestrichen und jetzt kann
ich von oben anfangen und die schuppen
nach unten hin ankleben
[Musik]
jetzt dekoriere ich die obere torte die
torte soll schöne wellen bekommen ich
habe jetzt hier etwas weiße
modelliermasse und blaue modelliermasse
und die form ich jetzt zur kegel und
setzte dann umgekehrt aneinander
und so kann ich jetzt die
farbabstufungen machen jeder part wird
es schön durchgeknetet zu einem langen
strang ausgerollt und dann habe ich so
einen langen streifen und ich fange
jetzt oben mit dem weiß an und nehme
jetzt hier einen ball und dann einfach
so dienten ein bisschen aus und dann
setze ich diese wellen an die torte und
glied sie fest
[Musik]
damit sich das skateboard noch verziehen
kann stelle ich jetzt ein royal eissing
her also eine eiweiß sprits glasur dazu
verweis pulver mit puderzucker und
wasser zu einer richtig schönen dicken
passte die streiche ich dann mit einer
palette auf den cache bord und um den
sand effekt hinzubekommen strich dann
noch zertrümmerte kekse drauf jetzt gar
nicht orte auf meinen tisch setzen
[Musik]
ich geb dir dort jetzt auch gar nicht an
denn ich werde sie bis zum geburtstag
dann noch mal separat im kühlschrank
einzeln aufbewahren jetzt setzt sich
gleich die zweite torte obendrauf damit
die aber mit ihrem schweren gewicht die
unsere torte nicht ein drückt muss ich
jetzt noch kuchen dübel reinsetzen
das heißt ihr könnt einfach zum baumarkt
fahren und diese rundhölzer kaufen
buchenholz zum beispiel und dann die
hier reinstecken erstmal einen in der
mitte abmessen und dann einfach etwa
fünf sechs bis sieben stück hier
einsetzen
[Musik]
ich nehme gleich ein großes messer muss
mir nur markieren
lach mich nicht auf und damit die obere
torte jetzt nicht wegrutschen ein
bisschen buttercreme ihr könnt natürlich
auch dieser klasse nehme die butter
zucker glasur ich gebe ihnen ein
bisschen drauf und kann sie dann
draufsetzen
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt der schönste bart jetzt
setzt sich die ganze decke auf die torte
[Musik]
fast jeder sofort stellt sogar oder hat
nicht gewusst was dich erwartet wonach
sie schmeckt nein ich hab das alles
gemacht
das habe ich helle buyten rein und so
erdbeer frucht ein nagel und seine
waldfrucht creme richtig lecker ich
glaube dir deine freundin schmeckt ganz
gut und für den kindergeburtstag haben
wir uns ausgedacht wir machen mit den
kindern zusammen naturkosmetik also die
dürfen ihre eigene du sprung machen
wahre perlen dürft ihr machen und so
einen kleinen sohn lippenbalsam und dann
sind die mädels beschäftigt danach gibt
es kaffee und kuchen kaffee aber nicht
für euch nur für uns erwachsene sparte
pop und dürft ihr machen genau richtig
schöne mädels geburtstagsfeier geld ich
freue mich schon genauer papa darf
michael thoben gehen damit ist dein tag
wird ich hoffe dass ihr euch ein
bisschen inspirationen holen konnte ich
schon jetzt mal meine stimme damit ich
übermorgen noch reden kann wenn die alle
kommen und ich wünsche euch viel spaß
beim nachbacken und bis zum nächsten mal
und schreibt gerne welche motiv tut ihr
euch als nächstes wünscht
die haben
[Musik]